[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the political journalists for the
financial times jasmine cameron chileshi
and also the chief executive of
conservative home mark wallace and they
will be with us from now all the way
through till just before midnight so
let's see what is on the front of some
of those papers the metro reports on
anti-semitic messages sent a decade ago
by the cricketer azeem rafiq who himself
has alleged widespread racism in the
sport in recent days
the manchester evening news is angry
with the government over its plans to
scale back the hs2 high-speed rail
network calling it a second-class ticket
to the north
the yorkshire post insists their region
has been sold out by the plan
it's not their lead story but the
northern echo declares johnson's railway
promise hits the buffers
whilst the guardian calls it a betrayal
of the north
eye describes the announcement as a
train wreck
according to the telegraph the
governments of germany and austria are
considering reintroducing covert
lockdowns as they feel the effects of a
fourth wave
the times meanwhile reports the home
secretary has blamed the eu's open
borders for allowing a mass migration
crisis in the channel
and that's also in the express uh who's
referring to priti patel's intervention
as a furious attack
and the ft is leading on an interest
rate cut in turkey
well we are joined tonight by
jasmine cameron chiles chileshi and mark
wallace thank you both so much for
joining us this evening great to see you
both um
jasmine let's start with you first of
all um and this is the story which we've
been covering on sky today it's on the
front of the metro and in quite a lot of
other papers
about azeem rafiq and these comments
that he has has made um
is he
does it does it make him a hypocrite
has he shown here double standards at
play com complaining about name calling
himself whilst at the same time calling
other people by names
i mean it's important to note that um
he's come out he's acknowledged what was
um what was said in these text messages
which were you know incredibly offensive
racial slurs he's apologized and he said
you know he's acknowledged that that
wasn't the correct language to use and
says that he's changed as a person
it's obviously quite an uncomfortable
revelation because just a few days ago
he was sitting in front of mps talking
about his own experiences within you
know racism within
within cricket and you know it was quite
a moving testimony but i also think two
things can be true at the same time so
his comments were offensive and he
rightly apologized for them but you know
that doesn't negate what he was saying
about racism and cricket that doesn't
negate the fact that the sport you know
has a serious issue in this regard and i
do think that one you know
one thing that we can all take away from
the events of this week is that actually
you know racism exists in all facets of
society and if we are going to be
serious about tackling it then it's for
institutions and individuals to really
reflect and you know educate themselves
and you know call out racism when and
where they see it
and mark it it is a a good point that
jasmine makes isn't it that it is
perfectly possible to be both a
perpetrator and a victim at the same
time um
do you think this diminishes though the
racism that he faced in any way or not
at all
absolutely not at all and i think one of
the unfortunate things that you already
see happening if you if you look at this
topic on social media for example is
some people i think who would dearly
have liked to ignore his original
concerns and the original experiences
that he uh has talked about in
parliament
and elsewhere some of those people are
trying to seize on this as a way to say
actually let's just discount the whole
thing that's clearly the wrong thing to
do jasmine's jasmine's absolutely right
about that i think there were two
really striking lessons from this
particular um revelation today the first
is that you're not for the first time on
this show we're having to
cover again the fact that unfortunately
for some people anti-semitism is
something that as openly expressed as it
may be they do not see as a form of
racism and in some cases i think is
acceptable and
that unfortunately is still one of
various battles against racism that
still needs to continue to be fought the
second thing which jasmine touched on a
moment ago is that frankly this is
something that sits within us and some
of our colleagues in many ways across
the media which is when we talk about
somebody and report them as being a
victim of an experience there's a kind
of culture that we therefore expect them
to be an innocent in every other regard
or they have to be perfect for them to
qualify as a victim or the victim would
make somebody perfect and that obviously
isn't true the fact is just as jasmine
says two things can be true uh
at the same time the fact is somebody
can as a zen rafique absolutely has
suffer
appalling racist abuse themselves but
still as he's rightly acknowledged in
his apology um you know act in the
racist way toward towards others and it
is sometimes we fall into these kind of
habits of well someone in a story is a
kind of goodie um well
not necessarily the fact his life is
more complicated than that
and jasmine
does this perhaps give us more
insight into the wider problems of
uh of cricket and the banter that
appears to be going on behind the scenes
yeah i think that's very true you know
what we've seen from these text messages
and from azim's testimony a couple days
ago but there does seem to be this
culture of you know racial slurs being
framed as jokes or you know insensitive
remarks being sort of you know
commonplace and being brushed over and
actually you know this week has shown
that you know racism and sometimes it's
not banter it really does have an effect
and should be taken seriously
absolutely um now let's move on to uh
the other big story of the day hs2 at
mark all of the northern papers have
gone with this perhaps no surprise um
let's just have a look at a few of them
well the eye of course not necessarily
northern but national the train wreck
furious pm rips up rail plans for the
north at the yorkshire post region's
been sold out
uh
the northern echo
uh johnson's railway promise hits the
buffers and the manchester evening news
maybe the best one second class ticket
for the north um
has the north been abandoned by this
government
i think the north has been abandoned by
by the government it's undoubtedly the
case that these headlines particularly
the men headlines you mentioned just
then are painful for the government this
is a punishing uh round of reports and
ultimately it stems from a really
fundamental problem with hst which has
been something that hst's critics of
which i have long been one have talked
about over the course of the last
decades or more which is that it is
extremely expensive what it does no
serious questions still about whether
this is really backing the right horse
technologically and the type of
transport infrastructure you want to go
for i think there's a really revealing
bit in the yorkshire posts the detail of
the yorkshire post story where there's
some back and forth argument about
exactly what kind of um alternative
proposals are put forward by various uh
devolved city region and local authority
leaders in in parts of the north england
and it's reported there that the
government has
um rejected some of these proposals
because they would be very expensive
cost billions of pounds and only add a
few minutes to journeys well that may be
true but the problem the government has
perhaps courtesy of its predecessors
whoever you want to blame for it the
problem they have is that that is kind
of true of hs2 as a whole actually this
is a very very expensive very static
form of technology to apply to
infrastructure for relatively limited uh
returns at least in terms of things like
journey times and when the government's
getting headlines like this about having
taken a decision
to not do various things the big
question a lot of tory backbenchers and
voters will be asking is well where's
the alternative story that the
government ought to be putting about out
about what he wants to do instead and
that that ultimately is a failure of um
failure to make its case
and jasmine how do you think it will
play out amongst all of those
conservative seats that were were seized
from the labour party in the north in
the last election
i mean we've seen from the front page
headlines that you know it's not looking
good and i think there is a sense of
disappointment there's a sense of
betrayal because even as you know mark
spoke to some of the practical concerns
around hst i think you know symbolically
this was a huge deal for the government
the government you know gained its
majority and gained a lot of those red
bull seats by pushing this agenda of
leveling up amongst other things and
there was this real sense when boris
johnson was elected that he tried to put
forward his case saying you know the
conservative government we are going to
try to create a fairer society we are
going to make sure that wherever you are
across the country you have access to
good transport good economic
opportunities and you know the scaling
back of hst it really symbolizes you
know the sort of watered-down promise
and it symbolizes that you know the
government's rhetoric was you know
leveling up and equality and investment
north but the reality is actually is
sort of watered down the fat and so i
don't think this is going to go down
that well in regular seats i mean time
will tell i mean hst was a very
contentious project and i'm sure there
are some who you know were relieved that
you know it's been scaled back um you
know as mark leaded to the costs but
yeah ultimately a lot of voters lent the
tories their seats in 2019 and johnson's
aware of that and so i think he's you
know on very thin ice at the moment
i think the thing i would add very
quickly is that
a lot of it depends on the exact
constituency so
it's worth remembering that just because
hs2 might run through your constituency
doesn't mean it necessarily provides a
trained service for your constituency so
undoubtedly for some of these
constituencies interestingly
constituencies where the labour party
was facing a lot of complaints about the
roots running through quite a lot of
what were then labour constituencies
several of those have now fallen to the
conservatives of the 2019 election in
the red wall where actually you what
you're talking some of the views you
find on hs2 are much more similar to say
some of those being especially
um cheshire and amazon for example about
the impact of the line going through the
constituency without the station
actually being particularly close and
therefore without the benefit being
directly felt the question is is the
government saying instead well actually
for your area there's going to be road
upgrades or improved bus services or
your other types of development and
leveling up and you know jasmine's right
you need if you're going to promise
leveling up and then not do this
particular thing there needs to be an
explanation of what's going to happen
instead
um just before we take the break a
little bit of light relief on this story
uh from matt
uh in the telegraph as always um always
on the nose uh santa's sitting there i
deliver presents to children all over
the world
well i don't go as far as leads
coming up after the break we'll have
more from our two favorite viewers uh
including the story about the justice
secretary saying that tory mps bear a
collective responsibility for
allegations of sleaze we'll discuss that
next
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me now jasmine cameron chileshi and mark
wallace
now the story you've chosen to look at
in this section is from inside the metro
uh let's start with you mark this is all
about tori sleeves dominic rob saying
that
they're all in it together
there's a there's a rare bit of tory
solidarity for you
well it's it read between the lines and
it doesn't necessarily read purely as a
generous hearted solidarity yeah i think
the metro of um in this headlines a bit
of a misfire from the metro and that i
ironically they've kind of tried to
bracket donald robin something he didn't
actually seem quite to say he was asked
about this comment from the prime
minister which he gave to the 1922
committee the the collected um
backbenchers of the conservative party
in which he said
i've crashed the car into a ditch i'm
gonna get the car out of the ditch and i
think dominic robert mike saying was
asked whether he was a passenger in that
car he said well we're all in it
together and we take collective
responsibility that's true it's
undoubtedly you know it's undoubtedly
the case that the cabin are bound by
that by that principle but this also
really helps to it helps to illustrate
one reason why there's so much
frustration and back bench and dare say
in some cases not not so backbench about
the decision making in the government uh
went into about how it decided to
address the patterson rail the fact that
they decided to get into you know
there's an old kind of adage that if
it's government business you can you you
whip it if it's house business
parliamentary business it starts to get
very dangerous to to to whip things like
that and this is exactly why there is a
lot of annoyance uh on the tory benches
including it's gonna be said from
advocates and supporters and allies of
the government who were encouraged to go
onto the airwaves to um you know really
fight a hard line on this only to find
the downing street retreated from its
own mistaken position shortly afterwards
which frankly nobody likes doing i
suspect the longer term impact of that
will be that perhaps quite a few more
people might find that they're washing
their hair next time they're asked to
stick their neck out
jasmine you know it's been a few weeks
now and it just doesn't seem to go away
this story does it
no and i think i remember it was a
couple of weeks ago there was a minister
saying you know on the broadcast rounds
that it was just the westminster storm
and the teacup and you know it's really
you know gone beyond what i think a lot
of people thought but john and mark is
right to say that johnson's still in
quite a lot of hot water with his party
there's a sense of frustration that you
know what started off with a government
misstep over the owen patterson case has
ended up with everyone you know rifling
through the register of interest and
calculating how much mps are running on
the side and i think this whole affair
really has chipped away at johnson's
credibility among his own back benches
really because there is a sense of you
know if we're going to be whipped into
you know
voting for unpopular decisions and the
government's going to turn around and
you know reverse them
what's the point in doing that and i do
think you know there are probably many
mps who were frustrated at the fact that
you know potentially they're going to be
asked to ditch their second jobs or
their consultancy gigs because we missed
that by the government and so i think
there's just a sense of frustration um
that it's all led to this and i don't
actually think it's going you know
anywhere any anytime soon and you know
we'll have to wait and see as to whether
the new rules proposed by johnson
actually go far enough and you know what
the logistics and practicalities among
those are yeah we should love to see
thank you both very much for now
mark wallace from conservative home and
jasmine cameron chuleshi thank you both
so much